while I remembered that I watched it I
watched um I watched the new Storm movie
oh people love my movie reviews oh my
God here we go is this the loaded topic
Is This Love and thunder right yeah oh
[ __ ] yeah I've heard it was [ __ ] I'm
seriously awful what a way I I never
gone to a Marvel movie before this this
badly and felt like I literally just
watched a filler I just watched filler
yeah I don't know what the [ __ ] did and
these [ __ ] online will be like
no no you have to watch this because you
need to know that that Thor uh had X
happen because this is gonna happen in
the next movie and it's like bro this
could have been a cliff notes this did
not matter at all yeah who cares who the
West
who who you're such a bad movie I don't
think that's a hot take though I've seen
a lot of people talk about the new Thor
movie and just say it was bad well not
bad very very mediocre kind of was
wasn't even a Marvel movie it was like a
comedy movie that's what I heard I'm
gonna start reading all the movies that
we talk about on the show four out of
3.5 out of 10. oh that low what five
would be meh I actually felt like I
wasted my time wow and I really feel
like that about movies yeah because you
you said the Multiverse of Madness was
[ __ ] oh it was like a five that was a
five five I watched it because I I
watched it afterwards
um and I didn't go to see in cinemas
because because of Conor's raging review
so I was like I don't need to watch this
in cinemas and then I watched it uh when
it came out and uh came out on streaming
platforms I thought it was okay not as
bad as like what you were making out to
be I think I think I'm just way more
invested in the whole Marvel Cinematic
Universe than you are and I think Marvel
has got to a point now where it's just
basically a [ __ ] anime at this point
you know marvel the MCU is the Western
anime okay it's the Western equivalent
of anime right yeah yeah I mean I don't
know it's just it's again it's so I
don't know it's so boring now like after
end game I feel like they've just been
stumbling right again to find something
and they're building up these this weird
stuff and she feels like who who cares
no I think I think because they I think
I think Marvel's going through two
problems right now one is like end game
happened and they've obviously when
you've had 10 years worth of build up
into like one [ __ ] film or two films
obviously you're not gonna be able to
follow that up immediately
um and the second thing is that there's
just too many [ __ ] things right now
because I think they've just how do you
keep up with it yeah because I think
they just announced all of the films in
Phase five and the end of phase six as
well which is going to be like the next
Avengers right the next the next the
next two Avengers film is going to be
all the way in phase six now yeah
um and I I believe there are more films
coming out in one year than there is in
the entirety of phase one of MCU and
like how how are you meant to [ __ ]
keep up with that you know yeah I I mean
it's just a lot and a lot of the time I
wouldn't mind if I felt like I was
getting good movies but a lot of them
are just kind of like all right you're
just putting stuff out yeah it's like
it's like it's just it's just quantity
over quality yeah yeah I don't know and
uh yeah and it's like I I watched um I
watched Top Gun the new one that was
really good I heard that was really good
I watched it in four mxd that [ __ ] was
so good yeah because the chairs were
like moving around yeah with the Jets it
was so good I mean it was just a good
movie like it was just great like it
didn't try to do anything wild it was
just like let's just tell a story and
it's fun and it's good and apparently
there was like barely any CG in it
either yeah it was like really
impressive yeah the shots were so good
yeah eight out of ten it was a good
eight out of ten honestly it was it was
fun if you haven't watched it I think
it's still in Japanese Cinemas you
should go watch it it's really fun I had
a similar thing with you where uh I I
finally watched the new Robert Patterson
Batman movie as well I love his raging
reviews
but I like I like Robert Pattinson oh I
do I do too but I thought that movie was
boring [ __ ] I thought it was okay I was
just it was okay he was just too emo he
was it was like it was like if Bruce
Wayne listened to a little bit too much
My Chemical Romance you know I wanted
Robin Paxton to be in the movie more as
him I did too I did as well but my God
it was just like every time every time
he went on screen I could [ __ ] hear
Boulevard of Broken Dreams just like in
the [ __ ] background that killed me
was when he took the mask off and he has
eyeliner did you just come back from a
concert like to help hide his eyes okay
when he took off the mask I was like you
are so emo it's just hilarious because
it's just the covers the color of his
skin right yes oh my God I liked it it
was it too long yes it was too long yeah
it was far too long and the thing is I
just didn't think Batman as a character
was an interesting character I liked I
thought he was more interesting in in
this movie than he was at Batman
really I because I really really like
the Christian Bell Batman yeah but I
like him at the Dark Knight at the
Batman Begins I didn't really I wasn't
really invested in it I thought
I I I did because at least you got to
see like a character Arc in in Batman
Begins it wasn't as interesting as Dark
Knight I actually think he was a like
Christian Bell was a more interesting
character as Batman in Batman Begins
versus The Dark Knight where he was
mostly about the Joker right but in the
Batman I thought it started the same way
it ended in my opinion where it's like
Rob Patterson is sad at the beginning of
the movie and he's just even more sad
yeah because he's broken he's like a
[ __ ] up character because he's Batman
who he's a [ __ ] psychopath yeah but
like it's like he's not supposed to be
cool this guy's a freak yeah but like
they I think they made it a little bit
too on the nose with this movie whereas
like you know with the Christian Bale
ones it's like yeah he's a little bit
[ __ ] up but it's a little more subtle
I feel whereas like this one like
especially with the [ __ ] eyeliner I
was just like all right I get it I like
that Batman big boohoo I I really liked
the Riddler in the Batman like yeah I
thought he was a really really good
villain yeah but I mean we're comparing
it to the Jim Carrey versions
in terms of like Batman villains and
just superheroes right and in general I
think he was a really really good
villain I think like the Batman was much
less of an interesting character versus
The Riddler in this film uh because I
didn't really get a reason to really
care about Christian uh sorry not
Christians character I didn't really I
didn't really have a reason to care
about that man in this film the last
hour was just far too long as well like
it was a drag it was it was I'll admit
that yeah I'm just a champion yeah don't
get me wrong I love Rob Patterson and
like his acting was good but like he had
far too little lines that were even
interesting yeah I'm hoping that the
next one is like you know because we
have Batman Begins I hope it's kind out
of obsidianity a little bit more
hopefully Dark Knight but it won't be
that good but because if it felt it felt
like with the Batman it just came in
with with the assumption that like the
audience like you know Batman we don't
need to explain Batman you already know
his character we don't know his Batman
yeah but like to me I I still I still
want to see that character I still want
a reason to care about you want to kill
your [ __ ] dad die again I mean sure
no not again yeah every every God
there's so many of them I hate it I did
like though the fact that like the
Riddler they just made him out to be
like a 4chan yeah but it's great that's
great that's what made it interesting is
that they took an old villain and they
made it like they modernized him you
know they made it relevant they made it
current you know same thing with what
they did with the Joker with that movie
uh with the recent movie that came out
as well I just thought with the Batman
Batman was just the most boring
character out of everyone in that cast
for me because he was barely he barely
had any [ __ ] lies to begin with for
me it's like one of the there's a lot of
really interesting interactions and
Batman I again it's been like a long
time since I watched it but I really
like I really like the fact that how he
was like even the police saw him as this
kind of weirdo and they were like no no
what are you doing get out of here yeah
and then obviously the one uh the warden
one yeah the warden was helping him but
then everyone else was like commissioner
sorry yeah Gordon
uh yeah Gordon was like you know the
only one helping him and I thought that
was interesting because in real life why
the [ __ ] with this random psychopath in
a suit be allowed to like go into the
scene of the crime yeah and it's like it
would make sense right I liked how it
felt a bit more real a bit more gritty I
liked it I thought it was good
um but yeah I I always what would you
rate it out of ten the Batman
oh 7.5 eight and that's that's the
Connor movie
reviews uh Sonic 2 on a plane how was
that it was exactly the same as Sonic
one but with knuckles
I are they real and they announced Sonic
three didn't they yeah which is has
Shadows yeah I enjoyed Sonic 2 way more
than I thought I would it was fun yeah
it was it was a good time I think that
I'm okay with this being a series I
think it's just fun enough where I I
think it's fine it's straddled the
perfect line between campy and cringe
there's so much cringe jokes in it there
that there was but they they [ __ ]
they they owned it you know they owned
it you know they it wasn't that's like
Sonic's ammo though yeah yeah it's like
it's not Sonic Drive In general right
like they they got the essence of Sonic
in this film and so I I went into it and
I saw like one or two jokes I'm like
this is gonna be an awful film but I
kept watching I'm like this is an awful
film I'm [ __ ] having a great time was
really good as well
is great Jim Carrey's great yeah Jim
Carrey's just [ __ ] great yeah and I
think the scene that sold me was
um the dance battle
I was like oh I end wait what is it it's
just [ __ ] like they're like uh
[ __ ] siberius yeah they're in Siberia
or some [ __ ] and they're in this random
bar and they piss off this random
[ __ ] Russian guy or some [ __ ] and you
think a fight's gonna go down and then
like he takes off his shirts and starts
dancing and they have a dance battle and
I'm like this is so stupid that it's
like just [ __ ] loot around and become
amazing right Fortnight dancing oh my
God
that's that's the thing that's the thing
it's it's straddles the perfect line
between cringe and campy and it it's
just it just it's it it straddles it so
well though just it's just entertaining
like you're not meant to take it
seriously I'm hoping the next one's good
with Shadow should we run it is it did
you see oh I mean no I know it is yeah
yeah I'm hoping it's gonna be good yeah
yeah [ __ ] Edge Lord Shadow I can't
wait to see I can't wait to see [ __ ]
I can't wait for all the edgy [ __ ]
Shadow jokes yo Robert Pattinson good
like yeah surprising is wrong yes
okay now I'd be down for that I'd give
the Sonic movie uh if Shadow isn't
wearing eyeliner
I wanna say I think I have more fun
watching the Sonic movie even though it
was [ __ ] yeah than I did watching the
last two Marvel movies so I'll give her
six yeah I'm not surprised with that
yeah I mean Marvel to me I'm I'm only I
only like it because I'm invested in
what happens if you're not investing
what happens you're gonna hate the
recent Marvel movies because there's
literally like no reason to watch it
that's what I feel like it's it's just
objectively bad like if the only way
that you can enjoy Marvel is that you've
been you are dedicated to the Marvel
Universe yeah then like the movies
aren't good oh I think we should be able
to hold up on its own I totally agree
with you like the most interesting thing
for Doctor Strange for me uh was seeing
his progression as a character and
seeing how this affects the wider
Universe of Marvel I fully [ __ ] admit
that and I fully [ __ ] admit there's
there's so many moments in Multiverse
Multiverse of Madness that just doesn't
work as a standalone movie yeah like the
moment you talked about where it's just
like oh look at these characters care
about these characters because he's just
turned into fan service yeah it's it's
literally fans it was like there was so
much fan service in that movie uh um I
don't feel like Doctor Strange as a
character has like in that movie
actually gets anything out of it like
does he doesn't change at all like in
the first movie it's great because like
he's having to learn it all and he's
having to change his like assholish ways
yeah but then he just becomes Benedict
Cumberbatch yeah and then he just hasn't
changed at all or like progressed in any
way like at least Thor has changed a
[ __ ] tone as a character and it's
somewhat interesting to follow but like
I just find Doctor Strange really boring
to watch because Benedict Cumberbatch
has just been playing Sherlock but with
magic like the past two movies or three
movies I don't know what the [ __ ] it's
so boring yeah if there's one thing I do
actually recommend Loki is probably the
best thing to come out I can imagine
Loki could be good Loki is one an
interesting story two it's kind of self
it's kind of like self-contained so it
tells a self-contained story
um and three they make Loki's character
super super [ __ ] interesting okay
it's it's he's always been one of the
more interesting characters yeah exactly
he's been one of the more interesting
characters and they gave him such an
interesting character Arc and character
progression as well where they didn't
exactly change his character at all they
just gave him way more depth like highly
[ __ ] recommend Loki it kind of hits
all the boxes you want from what Marvel
kind of used to be before end game it's
an interesting story it really really
affects the wider Universe
um and it's just but you can enjoy a
standalone as well [ __ ] amazing watch
Loki probably I'm recommending movies
now I watched also on on the plane I
watched The Big Lebowski that was good
[ __ ] fantastic first time I've ever
watched it yeah that's amazing such a
good fun movie yeah such a fun movie I I
recently watched a movie uh I don't know
if it's new at all but like hockey
recommend it to me it's called Greenland
you know this movie no it's so familiar
it's a country yeah like like name does
the country but it's like it's basically
the most I would say out of all of like
the the world is ending like apocalyptic
movies it's probably one of the most
realistic like representations of it so
it's like it's basically just like uh
the world there's this giant meteor uh
or Comet or whatever it is that's like
flying around the earth and it's about
and like little bits of its debris is
about to hit the Earth but it's Gerard
Butler yeah yeah oh yeah hell yeah it's
just disaster movies now yeah I think
it's like his production company I think
so literally all he makes is disaster
yeah but it's him and it's like you know
like little bits of uh comments are
gonna like hit the earth and then
there's one big part of the comment
where it's like it's bigger than the
asteroid that killed the dinosaurs and
you know the Earth has 48 hours left and
it's basically like Gerard Butler plays
like this dad who just does everything
he can to try and get his family to this
safety bunker in the middle of Greenland
yeah and it's like and I I personally
enjoyed it because it made me super
[ __ ] anxious the entire time because
like they go through these like really
it like I think it perfectly shows what
would actually happen it's basically
because it's like based in the US most
of the time what would actually happen
if a situation like that happened in the
real world right so it's like you know
uh Gerard Butler's like family gets like
selected to like you know go you know
because he he's like his uh his
character plays like a construction
worker or something right so it's like
they pick out all the people with like
the important occupations that would be
you know responsible for rebuilding
Society once the Earth gets destroyed
yeah yeah um and then it's like all this
like [ __ ] about like people being like
desperate to like [ __ ] steal the QR
code and stuff like that so that they
can get on the plane and it's like it's
[ __ ] like anxiety driving the entire
time that sounds pretty interesting I
like Jared Butler as an actor I wish
that he did stuff that wasn't especially
smoothies yeah yeah I mean I remember
when he was one of the hottest names in
Hollywood you know for 300 right yeah
after 300 yeah like the man crush that
everyone had no included how couldn't
you how could abs of steel sexy [ __ ]
math yeah we'll see what was the other
Apocalypse movie that recently came out
not recently but came out a while ago on
Netflix I'd like Leonardo
I heard that sucked I heard I heard that
sucks I watched it yeah what was bad
about what's bad about it one it was
like [ __ ] three hours long and
there's just like dumb [ __ ] edits in
the movie that are fourth wall breaking
they're so frustrating yeah and it's
just like it's it's like a political
satire of what's Happening real like now
in the world but I feel like political
satire is so like funny and unfunny at
the same time and it's just like it's
really grating well because I saw the
one scene that came from that show that
was spread around recently because it
was like so you talk about political
satire but in that case it must have
been it was so damn good satire it was
so on the nose so I believe there's a
scene where they try to warn everyone
about the income the incoming asteroid
right on the news the news is just like
we don't do that here let's let's talk
about let's talk about something nice
let's we're here for Good Vibes right
right and then I believe recently in the
UK in the UK God [ __ ] come on come on
come on guys come on come on guys we're
better than this but in the UK there was
a recent interview
uh that was about the impending heat
wave that Europe's currently going
through yeah yeah where it is a
record-breaking Heat Wave I believe now
the heat waves pass but UK recorded a
new record high for the highest
temperature ever recorded in in our
country which is like 40 or 41 degrees
Yeah which is which is insane for a
country without air conditioning and for
houses that are built to trap heat that
is that is [ __ ] excruciating that is
dangerous people legitimately die from
heat stroke and [ __ ] from this you know
this is this has gone beyond it oh it's
it's a bit of hot you know it's a bit
hot and people like oh back when I'm
from back when I'm from ah you know it's
5 000 degrees where I'm from I was born
on the surface of the Sun I'll have you
know I [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] but yeah
so this uh weather expert was trying to
warn the interview on the news that you
know we should prepare for hard times
because you shouldn't take care of
yourself people are going to die from
this event events and the newscaster
literally said you know you owe you
whether all you meteorologists are so
you know you're so down like why are you
such downers all the time man this is
good weather how could you complain
about a bit of heat a bit of sunshine
and it was just it was so on the nose to
what to the scene that's the uh the
other film yeah the other film kind of
portrayed that it's it was it was kind
of like depressingly
depressingly accurate like I said it was
it was
very funny at times and very cringe at
times like some of the Saturday was very
good and it was tasteful and others were
very like oh but again I guess it could
be with your political leaning as well
yeah if you're you know you might find
one it was trying to make fun of both
sides yeah but at times just made it
looked made it seem like dumb right and
there's this whole like kind of there's
like a subtle art to doing that kind of
stuff I don't know for me it was just
South Park's like the uh kind of like
King at that yeah like if it's too on
the nose then it's just like all right
all right we get it yeah I haven't
watched South Park of late though I
don't know if it's good I don't know if
it's good but back when I used to watch
style Park you know it was very funny
yeah they were like kind of like the
kings of being able to make both sides
look stupid while also just making a
funny funny show in general as well yeah
I think they've definitely done done
some episodes there yeah they were bad
but oh yeah I'm sure what show doesn't